[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 en
2019 hubo 15 muertes estacionales o
neonatales por cada 1.000 niños nacidos
vivos en colombia son miles las mujeres
y familias que enfrentan el dolor de la
pérdida cada año y el fenómeno se repite
a lo ancho del planeta por eso hoy
hablaremos con la vocera de js fundación
llamada así en honor al bebé juan isaac
castañeda la iniciativa funciona en
territorio colombiano y virtualmente
trabaja con organizaciones de otros
países latinos para ayudar en el proceso
de duelo y dignificación de las familias
que afrontan la muerte de un bebé
médicamente es común escuchar la pérdida
de un producto o el desecho de un feto
después de un aborto y cuando un bebé
nació y falleció al poco tiempo se
discute el espacio necesario para la
recuperación física de la madre y se
dispone de los restos de su hijo pero
para las mujeres y para las familias
víctimas de las estadísticas de pérdida
es necesario que haya más dignidad en el
proceso un hijo no es un producto o un
desecho y para ellos el reclamo es yo
también tuve un nombre mi nombre es
lizette tengo 29 años
y hoy 3 de octubre hace exactamente dos
años perdí a mi hijo en la estación mi
nombre es lorena ruiz y suele mamá de
nicolás nació isabel ramírez mamá de
matías en el cielo quien parte de los 39
puntos 5 semanas de gestación yo tenía
22 semanas de embarazo y el día anterior
en una ecografía de rutina me estaban
diciendo que el corazón de mi hijo ha
viajado al latif el pasado 27 de junio
del 2020 di a luz en cali a mi hijo y
justo el día que debía ser inducido al
parto cuando me hicieron la ecografía el
corazón de nicolás nun al día
yo tuve que vivir una experiencia
traumatizante tuve que pasar una noche y
un día completo con mujeres que también
acaban de tener a sus hijos y que
llegaron con ellos en brazos creo que lo
más duro de todo después de un parto
doloroso un parto de llanto
porque no es ahora solo
para ir a mi hijo
era que yo sabía que en el momento en
que lo perdiera ya no iba a estar
conmigo es doloroso empezar un trabajo
de parto sabiendo que al final el
resultado no será el mismo
y que al final con un cuerpo adolorido
frágil con un corazón roto y unos brazos
vacíos
el personal médico únicamente de ocho
días de incapacidad porque considera que
lo necesitas más y un partido
para tenerlo entre los brazos y que a
las 4 horas venga la funeraria por él y
lo quiten
es el momento más chulo de tu vida mi
hijo nació muerto pues nació
y necesitaba ser tratado como tal era un
bebé que merecía el respeto que merece
ser llamado por su nombre
[Música]
y que desde el primer momento llamen a
tu hijo
simplemente como un producto cuando para
su familia siempre fue y será matías por
eso me dolía tanto que cuando me
entregaron el certificado de defunción
solamente dijeron fed
y no apareciera su nombre estuvo
cuarenta semanas conmigo le regalé su
nombre
y el nombre amigo es nicolás
[Música]
no iré encantado del pollo registro
amigo
porque siempre existirá de nuestros
conexiones porque no es en ti lleno de
vida en mi vientre y porque siempre lo
llame por su nombre con respeto por los
testimonios de que presentamos aquí el
objetivo es entender los derechos de las
mujeres que están en situación de
pérdida y por qué fallan tanto los
sistemas de salud en atender a los
pacientes como seres integrales nos
acompaña desde bogotá a la fundadora de
js fundación
angela maría muñoz angela bienvenida a
ellas hoy y usted inició este trabajo
después de haber vivido su propia
pérdida a partir de ahí eligió no sólo
hablar de usted sino por tantas mujeres
que pasan por esta situación
cuéntenos el punto de vista de las
madres que sienten que no se les trató
dignamente
gracias a angela y bueno mira realmente
esta es una situación que viene
presentándose hace mucho tiempo y yo
decidí crear esta fundación porque tuve
la experiencia porque no fui atendida de
la manera adecuada cuando murió mi hijo
y me encontré con un entorno no solo
sanitario sino social
y político también en donde no se válida
la muerte de un bebé no se valida el
dolor del padre y la madre y por ende no
hay un acompañamiento adecuado cuando
empecé a conectarme con otras mujeres
que habían pasado por una experiencia
similar ya fuera en gestación o en etapa
neonatal que es vamos al poco tiempo de
nacer me encontré con que yo no era la
única angela y que lamentablemente en
distinta en distintas instituciones de
salud tanto públicas como privadas se
estaba viviendo la misma situación una
mujer que perdió a su hijo aún tiene que
vivir un proceso de posparto entonces
quisiera que nos centráramos en eso aún
tiene que haber un proceso de
recuperación que cuando es el caso de
pérdida antes del nacimiento está es una
recuperación física pero esta madre no
va a recibir la recompensa que
normalmente recibiría que es la
maternidad cuál es la foto de una crisis
así mira esta es una maternidad de
brazos vacíos y pechos llenos como la
denominamos la foto es muy dolorosa
porque en primer lugar a ti te entregan
a tu bebé sin vida entonces tú necesitas
verlo
necesita sostenerlo esto no se permite
necesitas fotografiarlo porque no vas a
tener la posibilidad de hacer ningún
tipo de recuerdo posterior necesitas ser
informado sobre tu lactancia a las
mujeres no se nos está informando sobre
las alternativas en la gran mayoría de
ocasiones se da simplemente la
medicación para suspender pero no se dan
alternativas de información en otras
ocasiones ni la medicación luego de esto
tú llegas a tu casa con los brazos
vacíos y no tienen ningún tipo de
acompañamiento en colombia estamos
viendo que se hacen llamadas posteriores
para para averiguar sobre el bebé es
decir no hay una actualización tampoco
de los sistemas y se re victimiza a la
mujer que está en duelo en ese momento
entonces en la foto tenemos una familia
en solidaridad una mujer con una cesárea
con un posparto con todo lo que
significa a nivel de cambios físicos y
emocionales y una gran soledad y vacío
por el poco acompañamiento que existe
son licencias de maternidad salud mental
y duelo algunos de los temas que ustedes
o que la gente debería trabajar en
general y es que una mujer que perdió a
su hijo no va a recibir esa licencia de
maternidad pese a que tiene que
atravesar todo el proceso de
recuperación física que implica un
legrado o un aborto involuntario el
fallecimiento de un hijo recién nacido
cuál es esa necesidad de parto
humanizado y de trato humanizado en los
sistemas de salud que no existe mira
respecto al parto humanizado las mujeres
necesitamos que aun cuando nuestros
hijos vengan sin vida se nos permita
decidir que aún cuando ellos no tengan
vida se nos trata de una manera empática
respetuosa que nos garantice el cuidado
en ese momento emocional qué pasa con la
licencia en colombia en este momento
solamente se otorga licencia de
maternidad a quien ha tenido su hijo
vivo aunque sea por una hora pero quien
no ha tenido su hijo vivo es decir
muerte gestacional o muerte fetal como
es denominada desde la medicina no tiene
licencia de maternidad sino algo que han
denominado descanso remunerado por
aborto entonces mientras una
cuyo hijo nace y tiene dos horas de vida
tiene 18 semanas mientras que una mujer
cuyo hijo falleció puede ser a término
pero en el gestación solamente tiene de
2 a 4 semanas
esto genera unas inequidades enormes en
los derechos de las mujeres pero además
imagínate una mujer con cesárea tener
que regresar a su trabajo luego de tres
semanas todavía con los síntomas del
embarazo en su cuerpo emocionalmente muy
afectada y sin ningún tipo de sostén
emocional esto tenemos que cambiarlo y
esto se parte también de la consigna
digamos de la lucha que nosotros estamos
llevando a cabo con el propósito de
decidir en políticas públicas porque
sabemos que esto se tiene que trabajar
de fondo esto hizo parte de una
propuesta que nosotros trabajamos a
nivel de iniciativa legislativa bueno de
eso le quería preguntar también muy
rápidamente porque claro se llevó un
proyecto al congreso en el que ustedes
se piden que voluntariamente las madres
que así lo deseen puedan registrar a sus
hijos para que quede un rastro de su
existencia y de su paso por el mundo
este proyecto fue archivado sin embargo
la realidad no es la misma en otros
países hay muchas naciones que permiten
este registro voluntario porque la
importante
de que ese nombre no solo sea reconocido
por la familia sino por el estado
mira lamentablemente en muchos estados
en muchos países incluido colombia no
existe un registro simbólico ni la
posibilidad de darle un nombre a tu hijo
de manera que puedas validar ante la
sociedad se expidió un certificado de
función en donde solamente está el
nombre de la madre ni siquiera del padre
entonces nosotros lo que estamos
buscando es que se pueda dar un nombre a
ese hijo y se pueda validar ante la
sociedad que más se busca que se obligue
a las instituciones de salud a la
entrega del cuerpo tú no puedes cerrar
un duelo si no tienes el cuerpo para
poder hacer todo el ritual funerario te
pide también un protocolo de atención
expedido por el ministerio de salud que
establezca una serie de pautas y
orientaciones para garantizar una
atención adecuada en la institución y
por último pues una manejo distinto con
la 'la y con la licencia que se puedan
tener unas semanas adicionales esto en
colombia no se tiene como nada lo que yo
te ha hablado tenemos países por ejemplo
como chile donde hace dos años se aprobó
el proyecto de ley en donde se permite
el registro tenemos países como
guatemala donde existe puerto rico
españa-francia paraguay alemania austria
es decir esto no es nuevo ángela
necesitamos empezar a darle una vuelta a
la manera como estamos legislando
lamentablemente fue archivado ni
siquiera se llevó un debate profundo
porque no se le da la importancia que
tiene el hecho de gestar un hijo ni
siquiera se les está dando la relevancia
de hijo a quien a quien se tiene del
vientre bueno angela me quedan solamente
unos segundos o para esta última
pregunta y le pido que me responda muy
rápidamente y es que lamentablemente
como decíamos muchas veces este bebé
está perdida se considera un producto un
desecho el efecto que se perdió cuando
un bebé debe considerarse precisamente
así bebé y por qué no debemos llamarles
un producto de un aborto por ejemplo
mira tenemos dos miradas en este tema
uno en la mirada médica si tú hables
desde la medicina hay unos términos que
ellos tienen determinados y cuando tú
hablas del producto cuando hablas del
aborto pero es que estamos hablando
desde la perspectiva de la humanización
en donde el ser humano es el centro
mientras haya una mujer que espera a su
bebé que quiere a su bebé no debemos
hablar de producto defecto porque
estamos deshumanizando estamos
reduciendo a un desecho clínico en la
vida a lo que es fruto del amor entre
los seres humanos y a lo que para una
mujer es su hijo porque el vínculo no se
da desde que tú ves a tu hijo respirar
una vez se ha separado de ti sino desde
que lo deseas y sabes que viene en
camino por eso no podemos comparar un
bebé con un desecho y este es un llamado
para que volvamos la mirada al centro a
la importancia de la familia al poder
nosotros comprender que lo que hay en
esa gestación no es un resto no son
células es un ser humano y darle la
dignidad que se merece angela gracias
por estar con nosotros en ellos hoy nos
deja muchas cosas para pensar
y hablaremos próximamente sigan con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]